let's say you want to transfer a file
from one computer to another and it is
really important to know that it's got
their intact in one piece um you could
send it multiple times and then compare
them all but what generally gets used is
something called a hash algorithm a hash
algorithm is kind of like the check
digit in a barcode or on a credit card I
think James grime talked about this a
long long time ago on numberphile the
last digit in a barcode or on a credit
card is determined by all the other
digits on it and if you change one of
those digits the last one changes as
well so as you type it into a computer
you can know instantly if you've missed
a key somewhere so a hash algorithm is
kind of like that but for an entire file
that might be megabytes or gigabytes in
size what it gives you is a code 16 or
32 or 64 characters generally
hexadecimal it's basically just one long
number expressed in that way there is a
sum up of everything that's in that file
um if you crushed it down if you do all
these manipulations you can crush it
down crush it down crush it down and
what it comes out with is this thing
says this is a summary of that file you
could never make it work backwards you
can't pull that data back out but it's
like a signature it's like a
confirmation that this file is really
who it says it is the simplest cash
algorithm I can think of I would just be
something like that's five add up all
the digits in the file R which is four
91423 that's not a good algorithm for a
few reasons
hash algorithms have three main
requirements the first one is speed it's
got to be reasonably fast it should be
able to churn through a big file in in a
second or two at most
but it also shouldn't be too quick if
it's too quick it's easy to break and
I'll explain that later the second
requirement is that if you change one
byte one bit anywhere in the file at the
start of the middle at the end then the
whole hash should be completely
different this is something called the
avalanche effect um if you're interested
in how this is achieved do look up the
actual algorithms themselves that
me an hour to explain sort of vaguely
how they work in it in a friendly way
but if it's your kind of thing do look
it up but suffice it to say one bit gets
flipped anywhere in the message then the
whole hash is completely and utterly
different the third requirement is that
you've got to be able to avoid what are
called hash collisions this is where you
have two documents which have the same
hash now obviously there is a
mathematical principle called the
pigeonhole principle you have if you
have 50 pigeons and 25 pigeon holes you
have to stuff two pigeons into one of
the pigeon holes that's a terrible
analogy when you say it like this but if
I explain it there are incredible
numbers of documents out there possible
like the hash meanwhile is just one
fairly long number that when we files
out there which naturally have the same
hash and that's okay because the odds
against it are so unlikely that we can
deal with that it's it's never going to
happen naturally but if you can
artificially create a hash collision if
you can say create a file and change
your name then we have a problem
and that's that's where security comes
into these because if I can make a file
that sums to a certain hash then I can
fake documents I can send different
things and have this signature match so
let's say I have an important document
something that's I don't know that the
permission to to go to the moon I don't
know why I said that
uh-huh oh yeah permission to go to the
moon let's say that it's got someone's
name on it and that file is sent and
along with it for other channels comes
this hash to verify that this is
actually the document now let's say I
can intercept that file and I can change
it but because the hash algorithm is
broken I can change it and change the
name I can change the data and change
whatever and I can send someone else to
the moon because I can make this hash
the same to carefully tweaking the bytes
now it's incredibly difficult to do that
in practice you'd want a massive file a
lot of computer code but there are old
hash algorithms like md5 which was used
for many many years which now have these
collisions
out in the wild and are considered
broken because you can get a file not I
can document with texting but a computer
code anything like that where it's
possible to send something malicious and
have it come out with the same hash so
this is important this is where speed
comes in if the hash is is too slow no
one will want to use it but if the hash
is too fast if you can create new ones
in a few processor cycles then you can
fairly easily create documents that
match a particular hash it is in a very
real sense an arms race as I said for
many years md5 was the accepted
algorithm and it's still used for a few
things but md5 is now thoroughly broken
because computers are fast enough and a
few so interesting tricks you can use to
try and create hash collisions
deliberately kill the problem with md5
is because it was used so much and it
was used everywhere on the web Google
has become an exceptionally good
resource for breaking them you wouldn't
want to store a password this way I'll
talk about that in the later video don't
use something like this for storing
passwords but people did many for many
years people did and a lot of cases a
word will be stored next to its md5 hash
for some reason if you type an md5 hash
into Google frequently the word it was
hashing comes out which means that for
pretty much every word in the English
language and a lot of other passwords
besides the md5 can be solved by typing
it into Google so md5 is is
comprehensively constantly broken so
everyone moved to something called sha-1
and now there are rumors that that might
start to be broken soon if it hasn't
already because computers keep getting
faster hash collisions are easier to
generate so everyone is moving to sha-2
which for the time being is secure sha-3
is going through the process of being
ratified by all the agencies now and in
a few years that'll be the standard um I
mean ultimately I should really
emphasize this don't use this for
storing passwords I'll talk about that
in a later video these are used for
verifying files for verifying
transmission
and that's all they should be useful
there is one last thing which is that
occasionally you will see download sites
offering software who sell you that
here's the file we're going to send you
and click there to download it and if
you want to be safe here's the hash of
the file so you can be sure it's the
right one um that's a terrible idea
I mean it'll verify you've got the
download intact but they're selling this
as we guarantee that this software is
safe and you can check it against that
hash um which is a bad idea
because if someone has been able to get
into their website and change the
software they're sending it's pretty
trivial to change that hash as well so
there you go that is hash algorithms
that is taking a big chunk of data and
turn it into a small amount to verify it
and a later video I will talk about how
that's used and how that shouldn't be
used for actually keeping things secure
this episode of computer file was
brought to you by audible.com and you
can go to audible.com slash computer
file and download a free book they've
got a huge range and you can listen to
it on all kinds of devices your phone or
in the car things like that I was
thinking about a book to recommend and
it made me think about the first audio
book I ever listened to and that was
Treasure Island and I listened to it on
a cassette next to my bed as I was
getting to sleep each night I checked
the audible website they do have
Treasure Island so that's my
recommendation today why don't you check
it out audible.com slash computerphile
free book and thanks to them for
supporting our videos